and finally tonight a group of local  kids didn't let the scrooge of covet 19  get them down  they turned a christmas carol into quite  a unique virtual show  you were always a good man of business  business  the connection middle school drama club  had planned to put on an  in-person play but couldn't due to the  pandemic they instead produced their own  parts over google meet and put it all  together with the help of their teacher  she says it really sparked their  creativity it showed us everything that  we could do  that was like untapped potential we  didn't even realize  that we could do something like this  unless we were put in this situation  and now even going back hybrid or  full-on  it's like we're going to keep doing  things like this this is really fun  really cool  the video is available for rent online  through the weekend all proceeds go to  the school's theater program  that's on our website we